Nick what have we gathered first of all
are there US companies that will suffer
as a result of these sanctions well we
spoke with senior administration
officials on a call this morning and
they were explicit that the sanctions
would not directly affect any business
deals with Iran specifically mentioning
Boeing's deal to sell about 80 aircraft
to Iran's national carrier so at this
stage no it looks like these are fairly
targeted sanctions that would not affect
any sort of business as as the economy
of Iran opens up in the wake of the
nuclear deal you know we spoke with
Stephen Biddle earlier today of George
Washington University and the Council on
Foreign Relations Nick and I just want
to play you something he said about the
fact that you know the u.s. maybe had no
choice but to do this have a listen it's
hard to imagine that the White House had
much of a choice for the Iranian 20 out
of their way to do something that
required some for us response so that it
would be unrealistic to think they were
just going to do nothing what they're
doing with frankly rather weak sanctions
regime inevitably week at this point is
there presumably trying to send some
signal the Iranians that the sort of
thing has caused the problem with this
though is if it goes much beyond where
it is now if the administration decides
a test escalade it's very unclear how
much real leverage they've got if the
signal doesn't work and hearings don't
knock off this kind of behavior so that
was Steven middle there Nick he also
made the point that the US needs allies
in order to sort of push back on this
it's a can't be a unilateral action what
do you make of those comments well I
think that's true what we're really
hearing from the Trump administration
right now is that it's sort of a matter
of tone you know when the National
Security Advisor Mike Flynn went to the
White House briefing room he said it Ron
is being put on notice so well you look
at these individual sanctions they're
very much sort of part of a pattern we
saw under the Obama administration where
Iranian entities would be sanctioned
that list is actually quite long now the
Trump administration is saying well
while those individual steps may be
somewhat similar these are part of a
sort of broadening a toughening of tone
against Iran
where the US will seek to take more
coercive action on the call this morning
senior administration officials also
told us that the US would continue to
exert pressure on Iran so it does seem
like we have not heard the last from the
White House on the Iran issue after
these sanctions davantes point does the
u.s. have a lie support in trying to
penalize Iran for the actions that they
took well I mean there's brother there's
widespread condemnation from European
allies you know US allies around the
world about Iran's activities developing
ballistic missiles and also its role as
a state sponsor of terrorism and it's
its role in the Syrian civil war so
certainly there are plenty of alliances
there however you know Republicans in
Congress and also the Trump
administration have been particularly
aggressive in wanting to hold Iran to
account so I would say you know in
European capitals the focus is much more
is on maintaining the integrity of the
nuclear deal and making sure that is
where the focus is and keeping that that
issue on track and that deal sort of in
progress whereas the US administration
is saying hey you know we're going to
let the nuclear deal stand but we really
want to focus on these other things
state sponsor of terrorism work on
ballistic missiles we really want to
hold their feet to the fire on those
issues and we'll leave the nuclear deal
alone for now